à la librairie du pinceret à poissie la
queue ne faiblit pas les fans de roman
et en particulier ceux de Marc Levy
avaient un rendez-vous important
rencontrer l'écrivain et se procurer son
tout dernier roman ah oui
pour la symphonie des monstre un roman
dans lequel l'auteur raconte les raptes
d'enfants Ukrainiens depuis l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie on parle
d'une certaine lassitude par rapport à
la guerre et on parle de beaucoup de
choses mais on parle pas du
tout du sort de ces an enfant et je
crois que le roman a le pouvoir de nous
faire ressentir et de nous rapprocher de
gens qu'on croit vivre loin mais qui en
fait sont très proches de nous cadeau à
offrir ou cadeau pour soi-même parmi les
fans des impatients et d'autres qui
devront attendre les fêtes de fin
d'année pour s'y plonger j'ai hâte de
voir ce que Mar lev voit lui-même à
travers ce livre avant Noël ça fait un
petit cadeau c'est tout parce Noë c'est
un bon mois et quelqu une séance
dédicace qui a eu du succès 300 romans
ont été vendus en l'espace de
2h merci beaucoup bonsoir Merci à VOUS
bonsoir